Guten Tag!
Mein Name ist Rana Yüksel. Ich bin auf dieser Station Assistenz Arsten.
Ich bin auf der Station auf der Station Arsten.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe eine gute Zeit.
Wie heißt du?
Ich heisse Peter Kaizer.
Ich bin 72.
79.
Okay. Wie viele Wege sind es nun Zeit?
Bitte, bitte was?
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78.
Okay. Wie viele Wege sind es nun Zeit?
Ich bin so ungefähr 80 kg.
Mach Sie. Okay.
Okay.
Ja, mach ich so.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für mich?
Pardon, hau'wun Sie im Moment.
Ich sehe hier, dass du den Husten...
Ja, und zwar den Husten habe ich nicht erst seit heute,
sondern den habe ich schon so lange.
Und das wird immer schlimmer.
Und erst dachte ich, ich habe irgendwie so ein Infekt
und ging es mir ein paar Tage nicht gut.
Dann fing das mit dem Husten an.
Und der Husten war ich mal so in der Nacht vor allen Dingen.
Sonst war ich?
Der kann ich auch gar nicht schlafen.
Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich kriege überhaupt gar keine Luft.
Und dann manchmal ist es so schlimm,
das ist ganz, da löst sich auch gar nicht.
Das ist alles sich fest.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, ich kriege fast keine Luft.
Und dann manchmal ist das, als ob ich mich fast übergeben muss.
Und so muss ich wirken. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwarten?
Also eigentlich geht das jetzt schon die dritte Woche.
Die dritte Woche, okay.
Sie haben Husten, haben Sie dabei Ausruf?
Ja, da kommt eigentlich nicht viel, so ein ganz bisschen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss die ganze Zeit Husten
und das kommt aber kaum was.
Aber da ist so ein bisschen grünlicher Schleim kommt daraus.
Ah, grünliche.
Okay.
Okay, Sie haben schon Erwandt
auf siehleiden unter Atmenot.
Ja, haben Sie Burus, Schmerzen dabei?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe diesen, weil ich diesen Husten habe,
ich mache manchmal das Gefühl, wenn dann so ein Husten-Anfall ist,
dass ich kaum Luft bekommen.
Okay, haben Sie in der Vergangenheit auf andere Beschwarten gehabt?
Nein, also an so einem, also ich rauche natürlich schon ewig lange,
aber für ein bisschen raucher Husten habe ich schon immer mal gehabt.
Aber das ist jetzt wirklich, das ist schon anders, ja.
Hat sich der Husten mit der Zeit verändert?
Ja, also am Anfang war das nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen ein Engelgefühl in der Brust aufgefallen?
Ein Engelgefühl in der Brust eigentlich?
Nein, ich habe eher so das Gefühl,
dass ich nichts ausrüsten kann, ja.
Und ja, vielleicht muss ich das auch sagen,
deshalb ich jetzt auch langsam Angst kriege.
Einer meiner Brüder, der ist,
der ist an einem Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Und deswegen habe ich jetzt natürlich große Angst.
Weil das auch so ungewöhnlich ist,
weil so etwas habe ich wirklich noch nicht erlebt.
Ich kann mir vorzählen, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich wollte, der saufel auf alle Fälle nachgehen, okay?
Okay.
Und ja, Sie haben aus Frusch, Grünmühe und Schleimige
haben Sie Fieberstürfrost nach Schwarz.
Fieber habe ich. Oh ja, Fieber.
Also ich habe Fieber sonst überhaupt nicht.
Aber das habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht erlebt,
dass ich jetzt im Alter noch so hohe Temperaturen habe.
Ich habe fast 39 Temperaturen.
Aber das erst seit ein paar Tagen.
Seit ein paar Tagen.
Seit wann genau?
Ich kann es gar nicht sagen.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch nicht ständig gemessen.
Ich war durchaus bei meinem Hausarzt.
Der hatte mir ACC gegeben.
Und dann hatte ich gehofft, dass es besser wird.
Eigentlich wird es nicht besser.
Und jetzt, wie gesagt,
weil jetzt auch noch das Fieber dazu gekommen ist,
noch nämlich so schlecht fühle, habe ich dann,
ich komme jetzt doch mal zu Ihnen ins Krankenhaus.
Als ich sie, hat es Ihnen nicht gehofft von Ihnen.
Nein, das ist überhaupt nicht besser geworden dadurch.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen?
Zum Beispiel gegen Fieber etwas eingenommen?
Nein, da.
Also gegen das Fieber habe ich nichts genommen.
Okay.
Wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe so ein elektronisches Thermometer,
wo man so an der Stirn messen kann.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich heute february?
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen über, wenn Sie Russen haben, ja, Sie...
Ja, beim Russen ist es ganz schlimm, ja.
Da habe ich manchmal wirklich das Gefühl,
ich muss jetzt dem nächsten Augenblick mich übergeben, ne?
Haben Sie sich schon übergeben?
Nein, nein, tatsächlich noch nicht.
Es fühlt sich immer nur so an, ja.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Kaiser, nun würde ich gerne ein paar Fragen stellen,
um ein Unfall von der Spiele Ihrer Erkrankung zu haben.
Wie ist der Appetit?
Ja, total ist der nicht so gut.
Nicht so gut, okay.
Also jetzt schön einig die ganzen letzten Wochen nicht, ja.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Appoudasur genommen?
Ja, ich habe mich jetzt nicht gewogen, aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen,
dass ich ab... also ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, würde mir sagen, normal.
Wie schlafen Sie in den nächsten Tagen?
Ja, super schlecht.
Das habe ich ja gesagt, dass der Muskel am schlimmsten ist in der Nacht.
Und da sitze ich oft auf der Bettkante und huste und huste.
Und hab das Gefühl, ich komme gar nicht zur Ruhe.
Deswegen fühle ich mich auch so ganz erschlagen.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschwarz?
Ja, so ein bisschen geschwitzt habe ich jetzt die Nächte,
aber ich denke mal, das hängt mit dem Fieber zusammen.
Okay.
Wie sieht es Ihnen aus?
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Sturrgang oder beim Muskelsinn?
Zum Beispiel Leiden Sie unter Durchfall, Verstufung
oder häufig ist es Muskelsinn, Brenen, Leubesinn.
Was verlassen, das ist natürlich schon ein Problem.
Ich habe bekannt eine Prostatorvergrößerung.
Und da, gerade jetzt, wenn ich so husten muss,
muss ich praktisch so einladen tragen,
weil da ständig ein bisschen was abgeht.
Und nach dem Nacht muss ich auch zwischen durch mal aufstehen
und auf die Toilette gehen.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, dann übernommen.
Ja, genau.
Aber manchmal?
Ja, das ist schon relativ häufig.
Aber jetzt bei den Musken geht es natürlich überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sturrgang?
Ja, das scheint ja noch so normal zu sein.
Ist Ihnen ein Herzrasen-Aufgefahrung,
Herzrasen oder ein unregelmäßiger Herzschlag?
Eigentlich mit dem Herzen.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe,
aber das habe ich schon ewig lange.
Aber eigentlich, das Herz an sich macht mir eigentlich keinen Ärger.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendein Schmerz?
Ja, bei Musken habe ich natürlich Schmerzen.
Das tut alles weh, ja.
Okay, ja.
Ja, Brust und Schmerzen waren sie frustrin.
Mhm.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich erschöpft, müde?
Ja, das sagt ich ja, dass ich nach dem Schlaf nicht schlafen kann
und deswegen völlig kaoben, ja.
Mhm, okay.
Ja, haben Sie Konzentrationen, Schmerzen?
Nee.
Nee, ich hoffe nicht, nee.
Mhm.
Okay, Herr Kaiser, ich möchte so ein R4-Geschick,
der auch noch auf R4-Genäusche hat.
Und ich habe auch noch einen R4-Geschick,
der auch noch auf R4-Geschick hat.
Ich habe auch noch einen R4-Geschick,
Ja, ich habe auch noch diesen Alterszucker,
das hat man auch vor geraumer Zeit festgestellt.
Und da nehme ich halt mit Formin ein
und damit ist es eigentlich so ganz gut eingestellt, ja.
Sehr gut eingestellt, okay.
Seit wann haben Sie R4-Geschick?
Oh, das hat man schon vor 25 Jahren festgestellt.
Vor 25 Jahren.
Mhm.
Das war so 10 Jahre später, also seit 15 Jahren ist das bekannt.
Und seit wann leiden Sie unterforschte...
Moment, das war gerade der Ton weg.
Noch mal bitte.
Seit wann leiden Sie unterforschte Fargrocer?
Ach, das mit der Brosse da, das hat man festgestellt.
Ja, 5 Jahre ist das her, ja.
Zum Beispiel leiden Sie...
oder müssen Sie nach auf die Qualität gehen?
Ja, sag dich gerade, ja.
Mhm, okay.
Mhm.
Okay. Sie nehmen mit Formin außer mit Formin.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig mit Command-Time?
Ja, ich nehme noch Prosta gut.
Okay.
Und dann gibt es noch so einen Better-Blocker, da nehme ich morgens einen.
Wissen Sie, in welcher Dosierung nehmen Sie ein?
Keine Ahnung, das weiß ich nicht, nee.
Ich weiß nicht, was da drauf steht.
Okay. Ja, ich rufe oder ich frage nach Iran House-Arts.
Mhm, ja, das können wir gut machen.
Okay. Auf...
sonst etwas nehmen Sie, andere Medikamente.
Das ist doch alles, ne?
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Das muss ich wirklich überlegen.
Gut, ich mich erinnere.
Ja, natürlich, klar, es ist schon lange her.
Da hat man die Geilenblase entfernt.
Mhm.
Und als Kind hatte ich eine Blind-Up-Operation, ja.
Okay.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Wie lange waren Sie?
Das muss so zwölf, dreizehn gewesen sein, das ist schon lange her.
Und Geilenblase, okay, wann war das?
Ach Gott.
Ja, das war so in dem Zusammenhang, wie das mit dem Blutrufdruck angefangen hat.
Also, ja, von 25 Jahren, ziemlich genau, ja.
Mhm, okay.
Haben Sie sonstige Operationen gehabt?
Nee, sonst bin ich heil davon gekommen, ja.
Wie sieht es aus bei Ihnen?
Haben Sie allergen oder Ufart-Rechlichkeiten gegen bestimmte Medikamente?
Medikamente wüsste ich nicht.
Und eine Abospeitung?
Ja, man sagt, ich habe so ein bisschen eine Hausstauballergie.
Ja, das kennt man ja.
Wenn man so alte Polster oder alte Teppiche hat und es ist staubig,
oder wenn man Sachen ausschüttelt, dann muss ich halt nießen.
Und dann kriege ich auch so rote Augen und es tränt,
das ist jetzt nichts Schlimmes.
Okay.
Gegen Lebensmittel, zum Beispiel gegen Gluten, Apothe, Fructose,
Habunze und Farter-Echigkeit.
Nein, ich kann nicht alles essen, was mir schmeckt.
Sehr gut.
Herr Kaiser, ja, möchte ich zu Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit
ein paar Fragen stellen.
Sie rufen schon seit...
Seit ich 20 bin, seit ich 22 bin, also schon wirklich ewig.
22, okay.
Lebensjahr, ja.
Wie viele Zigaretzen rauchen Sie?
Da geht schon jeden Tag ein Päckchen drauf, ja.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja. Also ich trinke abends so ein, zwei Flaschen Bier, ja.
Okay.
Jede Abends, ja.
Nur gut wie jeden Abend, ja.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Da, vielleicht noch so Bier trinken kann, was weiß ich so, als erwachsender halt, ne?
Okay.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese nächste Frage nicht, war so nicht.
Nehmen Sie die Droge?
Nein, nein, nein. Also Alkohol und Nikotin reichen wir als Drogen, ja.
Ich schütte mir dir so auf.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen, die häufig vorkommen?
Leben, Eralten, wahrscheinlich...
Ja, meine Eltern sind natürlich schon lange tot.
Aber tatsächlich, also wie gesagt, mein Bruder, der ist an Lungenkrebs verstorben
und meine Schwester, die hat schon früh eine Zuckerkrankheit gehabt, also schon als Jugendliche.
Okay.
Oder hat Ihr Vater vor Erkrankungen oder Ihre Mutter?
Also ich weiß nur, dass mein Vater an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben ist,
wahrscheinlich hatte der irgendwelche Vorerkrankung und meine Mutter ist sehr alt geworden,
aber was die dann letztendlich hatte, Altersschwäche oder wie man auch das nennt, ja?
Also die ist einfach irgendwann eingeschlafen, ja.
Ja, okay.
Wie waren Ihre Eltern, als sie gestorben sind, wissen Sie?
Meine Mutter war 88, glaube ich, oder ja, ich war 88.
Und mein Vater, ja, der war so Ende 70.
Ende 70, okay.
Und Ihr Bruder?
Oh, ja, das ist noch nicht so lange her, der ist älter als ich.
Der war tatsächlich 73 oder so.
Ja, okay.
Ja, Herr Kaiser, ja, Sie sind verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Ja, aber die sind natürlich erwachsen, ne?
Ja, ja, die sind gesund, ja, da sind sie.
Okay.
Was machen Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Mit meiner Frau zusammen, weil die Kinder sind aus dem Haus schon lange, ja.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie?
Oder sind Sie schon Rentner?
Ja, natürlich bin ich Rentner, Gott sei Dank, ja.
Ja, ich bin Retter.
Aber ich habe praktisch mein Leben lang als Erzieher gearbeitet.
Erzieher, okay.
Haben Sie Stress im Privatleben?
Nee, als Rentner haben wir keinen Stress im Privatleben.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie haben Sie vorhin geimpft gegen Covid?
Ja, gegen Covid, gegen Grippe oder?
Grippeimpfungen habe ich tatsächlich auch gemacht im Herbst.
Und Covid habe ich natürlich auch vier Impfungen, glaube ich.
Aber und sonst, ja, was man so braucht, doch die Impfungen habe ich glaube ich alle.
Dreimal oder viermal? Ich habe nicht gehört.
Meine viermal bin ich gegen Covid geimpft, ja.
Okay.
War du für Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nee, gar nicht.
Okay.
Und ja, das war mein Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Noch etwas aufgefallen?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt.
Inzwischen muss ich ja auch immer ganz schlimm husten, ne?
Das kann ich gar nicht nachmachen.
Ja, also, wüsste nicht, ich will jetzt natürlich wissen,
was man gegen diesen Husten machen kann.
Ich will jetzt auch mal sagen, dass dieses quälende Aufhör,
dass ich endlich wieder richtig durchschlafen kann
und dass dieser Husten aufhört, ne?
Und dass es mir wieder besser geht.
Okay.
Ja, ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen
und ein bisschen gut abnehmen.
Sobald der Ergebnis vorliegt,
würde ich gerne über die weiteren Schritte informieren, okay?
Nehmen Sie hier Platz und...
Ja, danke schön.
Ich warte dann hier auf Sie.
Okay.
Hat jemand noch Fragen, unsere Patienten?
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Es geht um Peter Kaiser.
Der ist 72 Jahre alt
und 1,78 m groß
und 80 kg schwer.
Herkals ist heute startet
bei uns wegen eines seit drei Wochen
Bestehenden,
Kustens,
insbesondere nachts vor,
dabei habe ich ja
Displos und
Fibers seit einigen Tagen gehabt.
Ja, das Fibers war bis
39 Grad Celsius
und am stürmbereich gemessen.
Und ja,
ja,
ich habe einen
Aber das hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Er berichtete überhaupt fatig,
weil in der Nacht er könne nicht gut schlafen.
Die vegetative Anamnese war unauffällig bis auf innerpetanz
und er hat sich in der Nacht geholfen.
Er hat sich in der Nacht geholfen.
Es bestehen einartliche Nikotin Abulsus von 50 Peckensjahres.
Und er trinken ein bis zwei Flasche Bia Abons.
In der Familienanamnese gab der Patient an, die beide Eltern zahlend gestorben.
Der Vater zahl an die O-Kart Infarctus im Alter von 70 Jahren verstorben.
Die Mutter zahl war scharlig an alter Schwäche verstorben mit 60 Jahren.
Der Patient habe die Schwester leider an Diabetes megnutus typ 1.
Und der Bruder zahl an Brunherkarschno mit Zebun und 30 Jahren verstorben.
Deswegen werden die Anamnese, die patienten, grosses Antrieb entwickelt.
Der Patient habe grosses Antrieb, Krebsuha, erzeit verheiratet, habe Kinder, habe Gesundekinde,
die Reiseanamnese war unaufwählig.
Die Anamnese sind angabend durch Amäkisten auf COPD mit Extrasarbonzionpin.
Was konntest Differenzialdiagnostisch sein?
Ich höre auf Herzabauf.
Woher achten Sie noch?
Das wollte ich hören.
Ja, zusätzlich ist Lavon-Untersuchung erfordertig dabei.
Was lassen Sie untersuchen?
Differenzial-Bulutbild, Asylnux-Parameter, CRPBSK.
Und für diesen Fall Elektro-Lite-Werte, Bulutgas-Analyse.
Die Patienten, ja, ist es, weil sie sich hier redest,
sie haben die Nieren-Werte, die Leber-Werte,
und Bulut-Suka-Werte, die Bechtung-Untersuchung.
Und auch die Bulut-Kultur, die Geh-Geh-Bin-Anfalse,
und Bulut-Kultur-Aufweil, auch die Hohe-Sphiebe.
Genau.
Ja, ich würde gerne, von der Grundkamp-Torax heranlassen.
Und Geh-Geh-Bin-Anfalse, CT-Torax, Heranlassen,
und von der Bausch-Billung-Krebs, und der Buran-Kerl-Krebs,
als Su-Chiles.
Ja.
Ja, das, oh, meine Diakose ist COPD,
deswegen würde ich gerne auf Lung-Funktion-Test normal wieder kontrollieren.
Und, ja, das Pyramit wird durchgeführt.
Mhm.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann untersuchen Sie bitte den Patienten und halten mich auf dem Laufenden,
was für Ergebnisse rauskommt.
Ja?
Mhm.
Gut.
Ja.
Die richtige Diagnose haben Sie bei den Differenzialdiagnosen genannt.
Ja?
Ja, seit drei Wochen ist es ein bisschen mehr Hussnobberfieber und Rauchherr-Anapäse.
Ich konnte das nicht so gut vormachen, weil das kann man gar nicht vormachen,
wenn man es nicht wirklich hat.
Ja, nee, aber, das auch.
Jetzt machen wir mal nach der Reihe nach.
Ich muss doch mal fragen, wie war denn die Kutin ab Usus?
Ich habe die Frage gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe verstanden ein erblicher Nikotinabusus.
Sie meinen aber ein erheblicher, ne?
Ja, erheblicher, natürlich.
Ja, genau.
Ich würde diese nicht dran.
Ja, ein Versprecher.
Gut.
Dann, mit den Zahlen müssen Sie aufpassen.
Der Vater war Ende 70.
Ende 70?
Er war Ende 70, nicht 70.
Also, ihr habt ja gesagt, 78, 79 ist Ende 70.
Da hatte der drehen Herzinfarkt.
Und der Bruder, der war 73 und nicht 37.
Das ist schon ein deutlicher Unterschied.
Natürlich.
Gut.
Und das ist eigentlich schon alles, was mir so aufgefallen ist,
jetzt abgesehen von diesem nach wie vor bestehenden sprachlichen Problem.
Das macht mir das Verstehen wirklich exquisit schwer.
Ich muss mich sehr, sehr konzentrieren, um ihn zuzuhören.
Und ich kann wirklich nicht sagen, was wir noch tun können,
so jetzt in der Kürze der Zeit sowieso nicht.
Vielleicht als Gedanke,
dass ich es mal wirklich mit einer kurzfristigen,
bäukopädischen Behandlung oder so versuchen,
dass sie die Stimme rauskriegen aus dem Hals.
Weil man sie wirklich, wirklich schlecht verstehen kann.
Und Fakt ist, dieser Patient hat tatsächlich Pertosis.
Pertosis, auch noch viel Bauch, ein bisschen viel Bauch.
Ja.
Und zwar, ich habe mich tatsächlich auch noch mal belesen.
Das ist ein ziemlich alter Fall.
Ich habe mich noch mal belesen.
Und ich habe das auch deshalb extra so beschrieben,
dass der erste normale Grippesymptome Krankheitssymptome hatte.
Und dann fing der Husten an und wurde dann immer schlimmer.
Und eben dieses Husten bis zum Brechreiz, ja.
Das ist eigentlich schon eher nicht COPD und hohes Fieber.
Das sind eigentlich Dinge, die für die Pertose sprechen.
Und er hat ja gesagt, er kriegt den Schleim nicht raus.
Oder hat das Gefühl, er kriegt den Schleim nicht raus.
Und das ist ja dieses, wenn die so ziehen,
ganz furchtbar, wenn jemand Kochusten hat.
Ja.
Aber eigentlich fand ich so,
dass sie ihre Fragen schön gestellt haben.
Und dass sie auch eigentlich das gut und kompakt wiedergegeben haben.
Da hat mir eigentlich nichts gefehlt.
Stress in Kontinent fand ich auch gut,
weil er hat das ja auch wirklich genauso gesagt.
Und jetzt beim Husten hat er Probleme.
Und ja, ich habe es gerade selber gemacht.
Sie sagen ungefähr vor jedem zweiten Wort, machen sie äh.
Das ist zu viel.
Ja, okay.
Und dann macht er, hat die Schwester, hat Diabetes Meditus, Typ 1.
Ja, also wir machen das alle.
Ja, auch Muttersprachler machen das.
Wir machen es wirklich alle.
Aber bei ihnen ist es wirklich extrem ausgeprägt.
Und das kann man auch eigentlich nur kontrollieren,
indem man sich selber mal abhört.
Sprechen sie auf Band und hören sie sich das an, was sie sagen.
Hören sie sich unser Gespräch jetzt nochmal an und achten sie mal drauf.
Es ist wirklich so, dass man, dass man das merkt,
dass es sehr, sehr, sehr häufig kommt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die ihnen da jetzt Ärger draus machen.
Wir haben jetzt nicht mehr viel Möglichkeiten,
irgendwas zu ändern an diesem sprachlichen Problem.
Ich hoffe, ihre Prüfer werden nett zu ihnen sein
und werden mit dem Thema umgehen können.
Und versuchen sie nur wirklich durchaus auch
ein bisschen langsamer zu sprechen.
Sie haben jetzt zwar die Zeit ziemlich komplett ausgeschöpft,
also auch gerade in den Befragungsteilen,
aber vielleicht, wenn sie ein bisschen mehr Ruhe in die Sprache reinbringen,
dass es dann auch noch ein klein wenig besser verständlich ist.
Könnte sein.
Ich hätte gerne mal von den Kollegen gehört,
ob das nur meine eigene Wahrnehmung ist,
dass sie schwer verständlich sind
oder ob die anderen sagen, doch, wir hören das auch.
Wenn irgendjemand sich traut dazu jetzt mal etwas zu sagen,
wäre ich echt dankbar.
Vielleicht haben wir einen HLN-O-Kollegen tatsächlich hier,
der dazu etwas sagen kann.
Keiner will etwas tun.
Keine Kommentare.
Ja, ich kann sie ganz gut verstehen,
weil sie hat türkischen Accents,
aber ihre E ist anders.
Sie haben recht, darum haben sie Frau Geld Schwierigkeit
beim Verstehen, ich denke.
Ja, gut, okay.
Sind Sie zuverlägt HNO-Ärzte?
Entschuldigung?
Sind Sie HNO-Ärzte?
Ich bin Hausarzt.
Hausarztin, okay.
Danke schön, aber nett, dass Sie sich gemeldet haben.
Na, bitte schön.
Schauen Sie,
das wir jetzt machen.
Wir halten Ihnen die Daumen für Ihre Prüfung.
Helfen Sie mir noch mal, wo gehen Sie hin?
Freiburg.
Ja, Freiburg.
Grüßen Sie die Stadt.
Und machen Sie es gut.
Wir halten Ihnen die Daumen.
Ich wäre Ihnen sehr dankbar,
wenn ich auf irgendeinem Umweg erfahre,
wie es gegangen ist,
dass Sie einen Fall bekommen haben.
Und was die Prüfer zu Ihnen gesagt haben.
Würde mich sehr interessieren.
Ja?
Und natürlich hoffen wir, dass Sie Ihre Prüfung bestehen
und dass dann alles super weitergeht.
Dr. Pupil, wir können uns nächsten...